in care homes nationwide families need
these swabs and strips they're like
passports for people with loved ones to
visit
at the reich's care home in yorkshire
they have a supply but it's finite so
they were as alarmed as any to see this
demand so high for such tests there are
for now no more available to order
online
while there are still supplies in
pharmacies it's nerve-wracking news for
manager selena her hands she feels all
but tied it's not a situation we want to
be in
at all but
you know there's nothing we can do we
can't get the supply we can't get it
and it could be devastating for families
like catherine's this christmas her
mother has dementia a renewed block on
visiting unthinkable
to see her over christmas no no if i
can't i've only got a few left so once
they've gone
they've gone and haven't there i can't
get any more not been able to come it's
like going back to when we were unable
to see each other at all
the prime minister insists there's a
steady supply and plenty to be found in
shops but in some windows signs said
otherwise
and the timing could hardly be worse
deserted city centres spoke to
heightened concern and heightened
restrictions daily testing for close
contacts not
whole available
might have to stay home
and if you don't know
you almost have to go with worst-case
scenario we will assume that it is and
then that's where your kind of numbers
and your risk kind of increases
and i think as a school you can't it's
very hard to operate on
maybe
in places like schools and in care homes
regular testing is now just part of the
system part of ensuring that these
places are as safe as they can possibly
be and while experts say that the
manufacture of these tests could be
stepped up quite easily the optics of
the fact that supply is low at the very
moment restrictions are increasing and
we're being told to be more cautious
aren't good at all
it's likely any shortage won't be
long-lived but christmas is close and
concern is high no one wants a struggle
to seek reassurance helen and smith sky
news